all right uh this is the time to check
out your health insurance and make sure
it is the right plan for you and your
family right now you can call the good
folks here from select health and get
your questions answered regarding health
insurance as the open enrollment period
continues until january 15th and then
you have to wait a year unless there's
some life event that allows you to
change insurance plans so 702
650-1101 is the phone number to call and
we are joined now by heidi
and a lot of people are looking heidi to
save money when it comes to health
insurance what are some ways that people
can do that well the first thing you can
do is find out if you qualify for
subsidies via advanced premium tax
credit or cost share reductions both of
those are going to help you to pay less
annually towards your premium and
towards any medical expenses that you
might have next year so that's really
the first thing you should do is is get
to the nevada health link or contact
select health and we could take about
five minutes just to walk you through
the process and let you know what you
could qualify for one thing to consider
though when looking at a budget is that
a higher premium or lower premium might
not necessarily save you money
especially if you do need to go to the
doctor quite often this year that is a
great point you need to look at the
total top cost out of pocket for your
care each year that includes your
premiums as well as any co-pays
co-insurance or any anticipated
prescription drugs you might be taking
so it really is good to sit down at
least once a year to make sure that you
have the plan that's right for you it
might not you know might be very
different for your neighbor but it's
really important to look at your own
specific situation make sure you get a
plan affordable for you heidi thank you
so much great information and these
folks can answer all your questions
one 702-650-1 zero one they're going to
be here until seven o'clock tonight but
now is a really good time to call as the
evening progresses the lines get busier
and busier
we'll be right back